für ungeimpfte sieht es nicht so gut
haus muss man an dieser stelle glaube
ich sagen viele weihnachtsfeiern der
finden auch unter zweig regelungen statt
viele unternehmen machen auch in den
kantinen jetzt kurzen prozess sagen hier
die ungeimpften da die geimpften wie
siehst du es was glaubst du was diesen
winter uns bevorsteht ich finde dass man
die 3g regelung beibehalten sollte also
menschen die getestet sind dass sie die
gleichen rechte bekommen sollten wie
geimpfte und genesene was mir allerdings
auffällt in der debatte ist das ist
immer eine größere diskriminierung muss
man fast sagen von ungeimpften gibt und
damit meine ich jetzt nicht
ausschließlich maßnahmen sondern wenn
ich mir die diskussionen anschaue die es
momentan gibt um joshua king mit sarah
wagenknecht richard david precht die
einfach nur fragen gestellt haben die
möglicherweise aus sicht anderer
menschen jetzt nicht so klug waren die
sich aber millionen menschen stellen
dann macht mir das sorge um die
meinungsfreiheit in deutschland dass man
diese fragen so scheint es zumindest
nicht offen diskutieren kann ohne einen
wahnsinnigen beck flash zu bekommen also
ohne dann platt gemacht zu werden und
damit meine ich jetzt nicht eine normale
diskussion wie man sich das in den
sozialen medien anschaut dann ist das
wie ja ein maulkorb der da verteilt
werden soll und eine hetzjagd die
stattfindet und das finde ich
problematisch da sieht man was diese
anderthalb jahre pandemie bereits mit
uns gemacht haben was das mit der
meinungsfreiheit auch in deutschland
gemacht hätten die grünen haben ja
gesagt er ja schon komisch sagt jetzt
bitte mal den mund halten das ist ja
schon heftiger ausnahme es gibt einige
grünen politiker die auch zum beispiel
sarah wagenknecht
gesagt haben oder geraten haben dass sie
besser nicht mehr auftreten sollte also
und das ist ja dann eine richtung wo man
sagt wir müssen jetzt mit dieser einen
meinung durch eine pandemie weil sonst
alles andere uns schadet und das ist für
eine offene und kritische gesellschaft
sehr sehr gefährlich und ich finde das
wird viel zu wenig diskutiert und wir
brauchen gerade diese fragen die
aufgeworfen hat auch wenn einige die für
dumm halten für nicht wissenschaftlich
halten solche fragen müssen in
deutschland gestellt werden und die
führen dazu dass millionen menschen dann
auch über dieses thema diskutieren sich
über das thema informieren und ich bin
der meinung es sollte keine impf
bestrafung geben sondern im motivation
denn bestraft punkt 14 nichts trotzdem
gleichzeitig interessant ja auch wenn
man die umfrage jetzt gerade gesehen hat
dass vielen menschen ja fast mit einem
gewissen gleichmut die
beschränkungen ertragen die umfragewerte
sind ja auch meistens pro weiteren
einschränkungen auch über diesen winter
hindurch viele menschen haben sich daran
gewöhnt dass ihre freiheit eingeschränkt
wird auch das ist besorgniserregend also
diese anderthalb jahre pandemie haben
dafür gesorgt dass sich unsere
gesellschaft in entscheidenden wichtigen
fragen bereits verändert hat und das
sollte ein alarmsignal sein denn mit
gleichmut durch eine pandemie zu gehen
und zu sagen ja ob da jetzt eine
beschränkung kommt ja oder nein das ist
gefährlich und auch sozusagen dieser
übermut einiger politiker das leben der
menschen im einzelnen im detail immer
wieder zu gängeln das ist problematisch
nichtsdestotrotz damit er mich nicht
falsch versteht ich finde natürlich dass
man auf bestimmte zahlen reagieren muss
wenn wir über todesfälle in altenheimen
berichten dann ist das ein absolutes
alarmsignal und dann fragt man sich
warum ist da nichts vorbereitet worden
also warum wird bei den alten nicht
schon längst mehr getan warum auch bei
schulen zum beispiel gibt es nicht immer
noch immer nicht luftfilter viele
menschen können das thema gar nicht mehr
hören weil wir das so oft thematisiert
haben den letzten anderthalb ja aber in
ganz entscheidenden corona spektren in
ganz entscheidenden probleme wurde
nichts gemacht